this morning on the dish this year's
James Beard Award winner for the best
chef in all of New York City whoo Marco
Canora grew up in the nearby Hudson
Valley where the cooking of his Italian
born mother provided his first
inspiration his big break came at Danny
Meyer's Gramercy Tavern and he was later
chosen to open Tom Colicchio's craft
craft bar and other venues then striking
out on his own he opened the
italian-influenced hearth later he added
brodo credited with launching a national
craze for bone broths and Zaidi's oyster
room which recalls the oyster houses of
the city's early days and Marco Canora
good morning welcome to the dish welcome
to be here we're happy to have you what
you bring us well we have a typical what
would be a typical holiday meal in my
household we always start with a bowl of
soup
that's broth based with a you know eggs
cooked in it so it's like an Italian egg
drop soup nice and then we always went
to a pasta course and in the holidays it
would usually be lasagna Verde Bolognese
and it's a lot it's a big it's a big
time commitment but it's worth it and
what is why we do it like once or twice
a year yeah and then we'll have a big
roast with a bunch of side dishes we
have string beans and and squash and
then of course dessert pear and apple
crumble with cranberries and the
breakfast drink yes a little apple jack
bourbon and some cider bubbly cider and
some cherry bitters some very very
holiday huge fan of cider too these days
there's so much great artisanal cider
happening especially in New York State
and you know you pick some crab apples
and you let them ferment and it's such
an old-school thing that I think it's
returning and I'm glad just because it
just fills the house yeah cider Valley
yeah so you learned your love of cooking
at the knee of your mother I did well
you know we grew up in the Hudson Valley
on the Hudson River
and we had a big huge garden and my mom
was born and raised in Lucca and Tuscany
and I was very fortunate kid I grew up
with really fresh food like we would go
and literally pick our dinner so we'd go
pick some zucchini pick some zucchini
flowers make a quick frittata and you
know my mother was a super woman and she
would you know get a frittata and a
salad from the from the lettuces in the
garden on the table
pretty much every night of the week so I
have this much of these huge holiday
meals - oh my god we would cook for
three days and then eat in 20 minutes
which i think is pretty common but we
really you know making the broth and
making the pasta and forming the lasagna
and you know the long cook roasts and
the whole the whole nine so yeah it was
a big part of our my life but also you
liked eating did you know you wanted did
you know you wanted to be a chef you
know I kind of got the bug early one of
my first high school jobs was as a
dishwasher and literally from that
moment on I kind of you know became a
bit addicted to that energy and to the
you know just juggling all these balls
in the air and it was just a lot going
on and I absolutely loved it still to
this day it's not all just Italian
Italian food you're also you have brodo
which I have to tell you is in my
neighborhood yeah the broth shop nothing
better especially today than getting a
steaming hot cup of broth yeah I brought
for people who aren't in the know well
you know broth is a traditional food
that's been around for for a very long
time all over the world so back in
November of 2014 I had this little
window and I thought that I should try
to sell broth as a hot beverage in a
coffee cup with a sip lid and it was
just kind of a whim and I didn't think
it was gonna be much and you know I
thought if I could sell 10 or 20 cups a
day that would be great a little
supplemental you know cash coming in for
the business and and it turned into
something a little bit bigger and people
really responded to it and it's element
so your first baby was hearts though
what was the it was concept of that
restaurant so that was 14 years ago we
opened in 2003 and you know it's funny
every
but he wants to know that little
elevator pitch of what hearth was and at
the time I basically said hearth is you
know our shtick is that we don't have a
stick because we really just wanted to
focus on great food and great
hospitality and have a great family of
people that believed in what we were
doing and to this day that's kind of
what we do I mean it's very much Italian
influenced it's very much driven you
know lately especially I kind of shifted
it a bit it's about nutrient density and
it's it's a great place to get some
local vegetables and some healthy clean
meat and a simple meal that feels
nourishing and energizes you what is not
to love I am Not sure chef they asked
you to sign this dish as this custom on
this program I'll ask you the question
we always ask if you could share this
Italian bounty with anyone past or
present who would it be hmm
I think it would be Leonardo da Vinci
Wow that might be at first so I don't
know DaVinci answer on the vet I mean
cool fascinating dinner day would make I
would say so you know probably be able
to invent some new foods man yeah I'd
love to pick his brain for a great idea
we all good idea thank you Marco Canora
thanks and congrats on the success thank
you so much getting that broth and for
more on chef Canora and the dish head to
our website at CBS this morning dot-com